what do you guys think of the statement
men want to be praised for basic
treatment
those are the same women that say they
don't do wife duties at girlfriends did
yeah or they I don't want to be your mom
those are the same people saying this I
think they're irrelevant what are basic
what are basic things
I don't know I just got this from what
are basic things I know you know can you
repeat the question
um what do you think of the statement
when men want to be
what do you think of the statement men
want to be praised for basic treatment
what are basic things like if they're
taking out the trash and like
I've been small things I don't need to
be praised but I need to be appreciated
yeah
yeah Americans don't appreciate things
Brazil and Brazil they appreciate over
there yeah who have you been with
Americans
well I mean how many
the bare minimum yeah and how many times
do we hear men should raise their
standards or Not Sorry women should
raise their standards
like it's kind of ingrained in our
society that like women are
you know like we're kind of better like
you're the supremacist yeah yeah
what do you think of that statement I
think it is it is true and women should
I don't care if he's if you got a man
that's coming home to you every every
night every day loves you what's wrong
with a little praise you want to be
praised if you make dinner if you put on
the own address or you know I mean the
house looks nice so give that man the
equivalent I think it's a good thing a
woman should embrace that
um I'm gonna say uh
I don't think she has to praise you with
words but more so anxious I think a lot
of guys can
can see their appreciation based off how
the woman is is acting so you may be
sitting at the desk and
she may you know get on her her knees
and legs and just start putting lotion
on you and your feet and just massage
you uh she may just uh go decide to cook
or give you a massage just think there
you can just see their appreciation
without having been to be acknowledged
via words
what do you guys think
I've heard
um you know don't praise a fish for
swimming because
um that's what men are supposed to do
he's supposed to open the door he's
supposed to provide
um but yeah I agree I think it's silly
because like no one is obligated to you
know do these things for you and if
you're in a relationship with someone
you should be showing appreciation and
reciprocating so I think it's a silly
thing that it's very too common yeah I
think if a woman doesn't like praise her
man maybe he won't feel appreciated and
he won't continue to do those small
things so I even a small smile are like
kissing your man or hugging them just
those small things
um will continue to
um to get that man to do those things
for you right I agree
do you do that
yeah I do I'm not in a relationship
right now but even if I if I go on a
date and somebody does small things for
me of course yeah I just have to ask
okay do you not think that is I had to
test her
okay I did have a question for the uh
I guess it might be for the ladies uh
somebody said that a man should never
leave a home without getting a nut
you guys think that's true please
I don't think that's possible every day
what if you have busy mornings here we
go
but I mean you can every day is fine but
I think there's like so I'm gonna say it
again A man should never leave a house
without getting a nut
I mean I disagree
can't be what if you're coming in and
out all day yeah
I mean I'm gonna say one time
that's fine don't you want to have sex
yeah
every time he leaves the house I mean I
mean maybe I'll talk about it in the
morning and say you guys living together
so you make sure you take care of your
man before he leaves the house well yeah
because then he's going to get it
somewhere else
but you said it's impossible no I meant
like every single time he leaves the
house what if he leaves the house no I'm
talking about in the morning in the
morning I said before he leaves the
house yeah so is he just leaving the
house
like I'm not talking about coming back
leaving come back leaving I'm just
standing in the morning whatever time
what's 4 AM 6 a.m 7 A.M before he leaves
the house
a man a woman should make sure that man
get his nut
now are y'all practicing that
this really didn't really this is advice
I've heard I've heard um keep his belly
full and um balls empty sure and I think
that every I understand what you guys
are saying like you know the everyday
thing that every morning yeah
um especially with kids especially with
kids and stuff like I can understand why
the pushback but
um it's like probably like four four or
four days out of the week yeah because I
thought the woman's sex drive increases
uh over time no I thought a single
mothers be ready
um
I I agree with you I I think you should
like I was just saying every morning
yeah and then you just sit there and
take it like it's not like oh my God
what's it like you're doing the work you
can also get some head too I mean you
don't have to do it in the form up on
your back ladies I'm telling you what
this is facts right you you'll be amazed
two things if your man is competitive
he's building something somebody's gonna
try to give it to him it just is what it
is right so the other thing is when you
give it to him he only has Focus for you
at that point because he empty he get a
chance to focus on his real stuff and
then the third thing is offer it to them
give them the option to say no baby I'm
good this morning and you'll be amazed
that might work wonders so it might turn
into four days a week right but give
them the option and that's just as good
you guys if you guys have any other
questions
anyone on the panel it's gonna open for
you guys if you have questions
I'm curious to know about your marriage
what is kept that alive do you have any
Secret Sauce that you would give to I'm
only charged with this okay
you got a girl you have to grow by
getting married at 19 uh group it grew
me up really fast
um and having a kid so you have to grow
really fast and um you have to assert
yourself in this world because at 19 you
don't know anything you don't actually I
shouldn't have gotten made in that team
but what it what but what life life does
is it forces you to either grow up or
you're going to get you know you're
going to check out
um so the first things you gotta mature
the second thing is is my wife she grew
and she believed in our marriage when I
was focused on work she was focused on
our family and in a marriage
somebody has to be focused on the family
when somebody is working otherwise you
guys are not going to make it yeah and
the third thing is I'm a man of Faith so
I I I I I make sure that I pray for my
wife I pray for what we have and and
then we keep that bond together and then
every day you try it and you do it over
again so there's no secret sauce it's
just work and somebody's got to be put
in effort yeah
thank you
let's see my P.O box for the channel
I'm curious being like a religious guy
do you
what do you think about like Born Again
virgins
there's no such thing do you think that
girls should have a guy wait even though
she like as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible